okay so i'll call the drain company
but i'll call with an accent and
misinterpret
what i it is like it's not drain
it's rain listen to this i don't
understand what they do and let's see if
they explain to me i think it's funnier
if my son had a party in someone
no they'll just suffocated in the do you
know that that's probably pretty normal
for them
really
yeah oh okay yeah the fact that there's
because sometimes the uh not that people
[ __ ] in the drains but
i think all the plumbing is attached
haven't you ever seen or heard of sewage
coming up through the uh through the
shower
yeah yeah so it's a normal that's a
normal plumbing issue i didn't know
right so let me
watch i'll i don't know if i have a good
accent now for this but let's see
here we go he said their income
good morning
yes i uh is
the rain
the rain company the rain company yeah
drain company rain
is um in the
rain sometimes
when
the rain it on the whole back part is
wet
okay
so easy stop the rain or the umbrellas
what would it do
so when you say it rains what gets wet
in the ground the people's outside
the
the uh
chair sometimes south side
okay
so uh
you are
the company the rain company and i want
i won
yeah
you talk with you talk go ahead we
because we have the rain sometime
outside sometime
or we need travel sometime
and they go on vacation i don't want the
rain you want the sunshine
right
so we're a drain company
the rain is like the water so the wet
come from the sky
right so so normally the drain is is on
the ground no the rain comes from up top
right right you're saying rain the rain
the rain
the
rain oh okay i see what you mean now so
so you have a drain
drain
okay okay
so so you so you have a a drain
wet
right so so so you have wetness
i say more moisture
moisture
or
the
droplets uh
h2o
okay okay h2o is that uh
no you're right it's like like uh
wet is the word wet
wet yeah like like a like
like a storm like uh
the
yeah when you go when you go outside and
it's raining
right
this is the problem
okay fix that
can you fix that or
what
no you so so when you go outside and
it's raining what's the problem
everything is getting wet that's right
okay so you want to put like like an
umbrella or something
maybe it's you're the expert so maybe no
no so so we don't do that we're a
plumbing company we we do
drain drain
okay listen so
when you take a bath
the water goes down the drain no but can
i say something to you sure i take
showers
i don't
i don't take bath because sometimes no
let me tell you when you sit in the bath
you sit in your own
stink you know you wipe it up but it
just floats there i don't want to take a
bath i know i'm not knocking the people
that take bad
but
showers is what okay good perfect so
when you take a shower
and let's for argument's sake let's say
i take a bath
no shower is perfect so when you take a
shower no you started with a bath i use
i want to go with you i'm just saying
that i take showers but your story
is a bath it can it's going to end up at
the same place so when you take a shower
but it's i i do that in the house
outside the rain right right so that's
what i'm trying to say we our company we
do want to talk to my wife
sure
hello
hello okay that was my wife
um okay go ahead with the story
so so we're a drain company
let me explain
we're a plumbing we're a plumbing drain
company but you don't know how to make a
number to set up uh umbrellas no
really that would that would be like a a
a handyman or a contractor or no no no
no no not built it's not built in the
ground or whatever just to carry
whoa
are you okay
hello
hello why here didn't know you fall down
i'm sorry did you fall down
no
uh could you talk to my wife one more
time sure of course
hello
hello that was her anyway uh
every time it uh
rains the
the wet uh gets everywhere how can you
and i'm having a special guest today
yeah you're gonna have to call a
handyman
you are not
hun you are not
honey
no
we're plumbers
wouldn't that make you handy around the
house if you're
you have to be handy to do that
unfortunately not for that
the rain it says
yeah we only do plumbing and drain
the rain and that's what we're talking
about sometimes in the rain everything
gets wet
right right so we don't we don't do that
type of work we do plumbing pipes
uh
i'm not
i don't understand what okay we gotta go
now sir no hang on hang on will you say
hello to my wife
okay i'll call back
and call back
yeah i don't i got it
hello
yeah i got it uh maybe disconnect
it disconnect
anyway
where were you
uh no you need to call the handyman sir
oh
the
you don't do the the rain
no
thank you for calling oh what is your
name please
jesus
you just need to hurry up
get out
no i know it's me again um you keep
getting disconnected um
can i tell you do you need mine you want
to write out my name no no we can't help
you so you need to call a handyman write
down my name
we can't help you sir
no
can you take my name
i'm sorry can you just take down my name
sure go ahead
guy you're writing
i'm ready to go h o
w
i e
you got that
yep h o w i e
m a n d e l
can you spell that one more time h o w i
e
m
a n d e l
got it what is it what
say it back to me
well we have it written down here sir
what does it say
h-o-w
i-e-m-a-n-d-e-l
say that out loud no thank you
not a big fan
[Laughter]
no
thank you
is caroline's idea for me to do a reveal
and i'll never listen to caroline again
what a surprise we have to we're going
to have to do a reveal we're just trying
to do that now
okay
wow the surprise in his voice i just
thought yesterday we should maybe get
approval that's what this is about
well even if we even if we don't say
where it was
do you want me to call him back
i don't care i can call him later too it
doesn't matter
i'll just get
i'm giving you something to cut out i'll
just get approval
this is not jeremy right now this is not
this is not part of the show or maybe it
is we'll see how that goes
hi it's howie mandel
how can we help you sir
uh uh
i don't know speak to my wife
hello that was my watch
great all right
thank you
bye
is that good
now is that good great
i think you got it
you got to leave that end part it's
howie mandel how can we help you
talk to my wife hello and that's the end
jeremy
[Music]